strip away or the fierce make up a
battle quaffed hairstyles and intricate
tattoos and the norse warriors and
Vikings are just like the rest of us if
we were all muscular and ridiculously
good-looking anyway sure their
characters look like that fit right into
the Viking Age of history but he is what
these 21st century actors look like in
real life
Travis ephemeral though he doesn't sport
Wagner's shaved head and ZZ Top beard in
real life
Travis ephemeral still looks pretty
Viking Lee with a blond beard and
striking blue eyes the actor and model
doesn't actually hail from the
Northlands of Scandinavia though rather
he comes from down under and was raised
on his family's farm in Australia family
is set to write and produce a scripted
anthology series for the History Channel
detailing the stories of some of
history's biggest anti-heroes and is set
to star as a gun-slinging wyatt earp on
the new series first episode Katheryn
Winnick it's easy to argue that Katheryn
Winnick is the most iconic Lee Viking
lookin actor on the entire show even if
she doesn't really hail from Scandinavia
she's actually Canadian and Winnick
doesn't only kick ass on TV the actress
has been training in martial arts since
childhood and boasts some serious
credentials when ik told star pulse I
got into my first martial art school
when I was 16 I have a third degree
black belt in Taekwondo and the second
degree black belt in karate she's also a
licensed bodyguard and self-defense
instructor so don't mess with a Ling
stud Alexander Ludwig over the course of
the show's run Vikings fans have watched
a Ragnar lothbrok firstborn son that
grow up from a mama's boy to a bear
killing warrior as his character is aged
we've seen at Sir Alexander Ludwig's
look transition from short hair and the
peach fuzz beard to a shaved head with
one extra long braided ponytail in real
life a Ludwig who keeps a beard going
though he doesn't walk around California
with a waist long Viking ponytail though
Ludwig obviously didn't play the child
version of be on in the show he has been
acting since he was a child most notably
Ludwig took home an MTV Movie Award for
best fight thanks to his role as Cato in
the Hunger Games
clive standin Rallo was one of the most
fearsome Vikings on the show and he
always looked the part with long dark
hair and the bushy beard in real life
however clive standin looks
ferocious as he tends to stay sharp with
shorts tidy hair and a finely trimmed
beard but don't let that clean-shaven
appearance for you
the actor has been riding horses cows
ting and sword fighting since childhood
and is also a Muay Thai expert
meaning you wouldn't want to challenge
standin on any battlefield Viking or not
Gustaf skarsgård as his name implies
Gustaf skarsgård is one of Vikings only
true Scandinavians though he looks a lot
less fearsome in real life while floki
is famous for sporting a beard and the
iconic crying makeup skarsgård stays
clean-shaven unprofessional just like
the rest of his actor filled family it's
a big family to his father stellan
skarsgård is easily the most famous of
the family having appeared in Good Will
Hunting the Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you may also know Gustaf's brother
Alexander Skarsgard for his roles as
Eric Northman and HBO's long-running
series True Blood and the title
character in The Legend of Tarzan and
chances are you know his other brother
bill thanks to his performance as penny
wise in Stephen King's it that's one
seriously prolific family Alisa
Sutherland in the role of Queen house
log Alisa Sutherland cumber which even a
viking king with her stunning looks a
trait to be expected in a famous
real-life fashion model so the lens got
a modelling start when Cadbury revived
its iconic flake girl advertising
campaign she since been featured in
campaigns for such brands as Calvin
Klein and Chanel among others not many
models make the successful transition to
acting like Sutherland already has -
we'll have to wait and see if this
Viking star lands more prime roles in
the future
Maude Hirst with a long blonde hair and
kind face Maude Hurst was a perfect
casting choice for Helga the wife of
Loki though she insulted Lee had some
help
her father is Michael Hurst the writer
and producer of Elizabeth the Tudors and
Vikings first dozen credits her father
for getting her into the acting bit slow
she told a view of the Arts I was always
creative I didn't grow up much with my
father I was raised by my mum who was an
artist and that's what probably
influenced my creativity
well there's no doubt Hurst deserves a
role of Helga it certainly never hurts
to have your father as a show's producer
Linus Roache
give him a crown and Linus Roache looks
almost identical to King
in real life aside from Vikings most
television viewers probably know him
best as Michael cutter in the
long-running crime drama Law & Order on
top of all that Roche has also made
quite a few big screen appearances with
roles and priests Batman Begins and The
Chronicles of Riddick
among others mo Dunford though he plays
the English prince aethelwulf and
Vikings actor mo Dunford is actually
Irish a fact slightly masked by the
show's producers who have given the
character dark brown hair rather than
Dunford's natural red Irish audiences
however are certainly inclined to
recognize Dunford as the actor who
played Patrick Fitzgerald in Patrick's
Day an award-winning Irish drama
centered around a 26 year old
schizophrenic and his st. Patrick state
disappearance in Dublin
Jenny Jack's fake Vikings Judith out of
a medieval princess garb and sticker in
some 21st century clothes and you have
actress Jenny jacks besides a wardrobe
change in some makeup very little seems
to be done to actually change Jack's
appearance for the show Jack's is no
stranger to the historical drama fans
may recognize the actress from her other
major roles as Annie Miller in the BBC
series desperate romantics she's also an
artifact of epilepsy awareness and
recently completed an open water swim
and a Spartan sprint to raise money for
the Epilepsy Society
Alex Anderson like his character Ivar
the boneless Alex Anderson almost never
sports a beard and like his character
however he looks a lot less scary in
real life and as you probably guessed
Anderson's legs work just fine aside
from Vikings Anderson also appeared in
Danish drama of war which received a
nomination for the Best Foreign Language
Film at the 88th Academy Awards John
Kavanagh you probably won't recognize
Viking sassier from anywhere
considering the blind oracle is covered
in an extensive amount of makeup has no
eyes and is most frequently portrayed in
his dark hurts John Kavanagh obviously
doesn't look grotesque in real life
which may be why you missed the fact
that he also played the Pope in a season
4 episode now that you know what he
looks like
you might recognize Cavanaugh on the
Tudors as well as minor roles in bigger
films like The Black Dahlia and
Braveheart whether or not
Aven or enjoys having his palm regularly
licked by Viking stars however is best
left to speculation thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love team
[Music]